vous savez je quitte une fois y un truc
dans la vie corps on n'a pas en voiture
ma famille mon église mes copines et mon
prono
mais si c'est pour ça que tu parlais de
poignet c'est ce que tu viens de décrire
un mec mes potes m'appelle dungeon parce
que chaque semaine ba je pécho la
différente mais ce soir là c'est elle
que j'ai rencontré une équipe pas comme
les autres hsbc ce qu'on dit toujours
avec sa petite robe rouge ressembler une
chanteuse connue ouais je sais pas il se
trouve à boisset lsf et des cosplay sur
son playbook la toile mais je lui dis un
truc sur un groupe de personnes qui se
disent silva ne suis pas le plus alors
pas j'ai enfin pu choquer le qatarien le
seul problème c'est qu'elle ne vit pas
dans le monde réel son genre de film
c'est plutôt à l'eau de rose avec anne
hathaway et channing tatum qui sont les
bisous c'est pourri
c'était trop ce mal qui trouve pas
carrément riolo ouais alors je disais
qu'elle vit dans sa bulle et on fait
tout le temps des bisous alors que ben
moi regarder tu te dis c'est pas triste
pour toi tu regardes ça là bas ce que
channing tatum il sort par les trous de
nez parce que je regardais ce que tu
regardes c'est du foutage de gueule moi
moi ce que je regarde c'est dur
dans les gadz'arts encore mal par votre
famille mes copines et mon prono au
savoir des choses d'amour ça fait mal et
le porno c'est truqué